uh we were dealing with super super
fundamental stuff today just to get
everybody on the same page
um we just started out by reviewing
Vapes at the sweet turn the top turn so
spinning fours in wheel playing sweeping
low turning around to reverse
you can hide trying to forwards you can
think of a golf ball being down here on
the floor by your heels sweeping past
that and the bell hanging not over your
head so hit your head butt up the side
maybe over your shoulder of your
swinging out the green turning around
um
we also emphasize footwork not just
swimming the coil a good way to replace
this just with the body is to keep the
arms out of the horizon
step back opening up to the wall your
feet are open your hands have swung down
and follow through for closing the feet
your arms come up the other uh
and the idea is that you want to feel
that swing that way in your hands
and really get the swing of the hands
and the opening and closing movement of
the body all that happened in unison so
that you're you're not like chasing
after your hands or you're you're
starting to go and dragging your hands
with you it's very
very IQ now
everything used in unison
in fact I'm just going to throw this out
there this goes on the video
um a general ergonomic principle is that
for every quarter turn of your body your
arms will go through a quarter turn of
their large Circle so from here to here
about the quarter turn of my body on the
compass and a quarter to turn my arms on
a clock from here to here is a quarter
turn
from here to here is both arms and body
for a turn if you're here from here here
of course when we're doing that in
motion is below spinning we don't look
like a robot going kick chick around the
clock but it's good to become aware of
those alignments those are Focus points
you want to check yourself on
so that every quarter turn of your body
you're checking for her alignment in
your body and your arm position
um
and we sort of you know took those ideas
back to
checking or spinning
we also got to practice tuck turns
cup turns instead of sweeping to the
front of your body or allowing your
employee to come past you behind you and
tuck me behind your body
so we did
combine the edge of the shoulders the
armpits a good practice here is to
effectively over the head
and sort of pause
and see if you can actually heal and
keep some control of your voice swinging
there behind your shoulders and then use
body movement
to bring it back out
really
of course it's a little It's Tricky we
can just sort of like dangle our boy up
here but so it's maybe a little harder
to practice in the low side term the the
idea one way to think about it is you
are swinging your POI past your body
bringing the hands up like someone to
give you 10 behind the back lifting the
POI up towards your armpit as you
flourish around sweeping off the
shoulders
so you could at least pantomime that
holding your POI instead of some
pendulums so it comes up if you're
turning your body and you're sweeping
okay next particularly
um
uh we actually started taking back into
something a little bit more advanced
where instead of just tucking near the
body you extend your arms you can start
to turn this into a flower pattern
something else
if we get a little left
let's see any
real key points that I've covered with
the sweet dreams and tough terms but we
did the handy spins we should get so yep
okay so with back to school turns
instead of just always going with the
Flower Boys we're getting low or
sweeping High we can do that sweet
neutral sort of like a windshield wiper
sweeping it across
acrossed
we can even sort of invert the
relationship so if the POI are falling
down or naturally want the swing down
and actually raise those up sweep that
in front of my face like a windshield
wiper and when the POI are swinging in
Reverse instead of going up and over I
could bring it back down
sweep off the belly button
so we can turn that into a flower as
well that happens to be practicing
really nice
clean control
freedom of motion as we go
and by the way for next next week this
is also this sweet in front of our face
there is essentially getting us ready
for just walking out into shoulder
Wheels
and this sweep right there you can in
front of our belly button is getting
ready to lock out in the hip reels as
well so we're laying the groundwork and
just plug this into like all
[Music]
um
from there we switch here is in the
pendulum we've asked people for requests
who's keen on uh
hybrids which we're going to work up to
hybrids
basically involve having your head
around in your tummy doing something
with one hand and a different thing with
the other hand and a great way to start
that out that really informs a variety
of spending is working the pendulums
spinning
so we started out with pendulums we
played with just
basically keeping voice only pendulums
and seeing what it takes too
long arm right up in the front of you
switch the windshield wipers here
over an extended them
and practice this against a wall because
the pendulum is a really great test of
whether or not you've got really good
plane control spinning
putting lots of tension into that that
helps flatten out your playing is easy
keeping a nice clean
cleaner control of your toilet so when
you bend them as hard it keeps hitting a
zero point there and there it gets a
moment of hang time so we play with that
play with pendulum practice your wall
and I wanted people to explore whether
they can really
turn their torso while doing that
and using this wall is feedback
to see where you can get to
um passing through your plane or losing
your plane
the real Pinnacle of that you if I come
over here and you get a good end goal on
this sort of the Pinnacle that you're
going for is
being able to you know sharpen up
get my torso turned
but keep my arms close on the same sort
of plane or either like right next to
each other
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
of my hips and movement of my whole body
to drive an appointment
um
from Pennington Play We
we got into spinning
spinning forward together Time same
direction and practicing just
stopping one chord and swinging a
pendulum while keeping the other POI
rotating
swinging back in
stuff one boy
swing a little bit
swing it back in
if that's difficult you can
really just let one boy come to complete
stop and get used to what it feels like
for this hand just not doing anything
while the other boy spins and then
bringing them back in
um
from there we played with swinging and
reversing directions
one point at a time
so I'm alternating right hand and left
hand
effects which is great
which is right switch is left switch is
right in the Finish
oh that's again finding where where it's
natural where do you work
so that was in Wall playing that
actually gets a little confusing when
you're in opposites on either side of
you you can also practice this wheel
plane facing
so that backwards the last one this is
the old way you can also practice this
in wall plane
where you're swinging both of them on
the wall in front of you and traversing
one butterfly versus the other and just
ice
and so forth all those really good
practices this is in the particular
trick remove all by itself it's a
concept it's something to
take him work on for months and months
and months in every possible position
that you can find it because it's it's
going to let you really effortlessly
transition
between
opposite direction movement
and
together a direction same direction
movement
okay let's see any anything missing with
that stuff
I think that was the media that
yeah good okay
um then what that did we just do
foreign
we brought it all the way back to basic
spinning and
Crossing this is mostly review
it's I
so we're spending together time the same
direction and forward and as deploy fall
down from the ceiling that's when it's
safe to cross them all with everybody
and I'm just part way without hooker
so you're Crossing all the way over and
then you really have to scoop up the
upswing here
on either side you need to get them to
stabilize so they don't just come around
with black in the back of that
and of course you want to get
comfortable with this with the right
hand crossing over or the left hand
crossing over and you want to feel
comfortable Crossing and stopping and
keeping arms crossed and controlling
that crossing the other one keeping that
in control
um I mentioned it earlier in perhaps but
I'm going to say here that in general
I'm trying to control your planes if
you're getting into some awkward cross
position or maybe if you end up behind
your back or something and your planes
start tipping on you
maybe this starts happening and you
don't like that
um the up swing is what's important
as before it passes the ground and
swings past that full of gravity if
they're really scoop enough energy into
the boy to get all the way back up and
over the top I spend like 80 90 of
people's problems with plane control
without getting some odd angles having
themselves is that their timings off or
they're just feeling tentative and not
quite getting enough
up and over and so it sort of falls off
of this angle and starts hitting it
so just remember that if you're in an
odd position your employer like bending
in at you uh
scoop them up
keep bouncing a little bit and that will
really help to control
your thumb
so from there we even played with just
for the more advanced people something
that a lot of folks haven't actually
tried which is uh basically a weaving
arm motion
but in together time instead of split
time where it goes through the week yeah
so here's
here's a three week weave in Split time
and together time
here's our forking weave
it's using the same arm motion
but because
the koi have shifted their relationship
half a turn to get from a split time at
the same time you end up having to add a
whole extra beat there before you can
support around
from the front
of course you want to be able to do that
in reverse
all things
and that eventually leads to since we're
eventually wanting to get into hydrants
this sort of like what I went out but
this sort of movement
eventually leads to
this sort of
head-to-hand arm tracing or not arm
tracing we could ever trace it thank you
okay
okay my words are working is coming
okay good morning
that was pretty much it anyone think of
anything else
explode